グーン
こんにちは
今立派な博物館って言っていただきました福島県立博物館で学芸員をしている小林と
言います
今日はおじカウント機会をくださってありがとうございます
私は影響皆さんに
博物館で携わっている仕事を通して大事だなぁとこの数年間感じていることをお伝えし
たくて
話をさせていただくことにいたしました
福島県立博物館博物館です
100物官の仕事はその地域の歴史を調べて集めてそして残して伝えることです
ですから私が勤めている福島県立博物館は福島県の歴史を調べて集めて
の
5して伝えることを役割としています
私の仕事はそこに携わってその博物館の役割を実現していくことです
ですが最近その博物館の役割のうち
残し伝えることというのも大切さを痛感するようになってきました
この数年間特にそうなんですけれども
その中で博物館としてどうその残し伝えるかということを行っていたらいいかという
ことで始めた事業の一つが2010年から2012年まで3年間にわたって福島県立
博物館が行ってきた
会津潤
真の芸術祭という事業です
この事業は福島県の会津地方にたくさんあります文化的な資源のうち
漆ということをテーマにおいて行いました
漆は会津では2400年前の縄文時代からの歴史を持っています
その歴史を持つ体も選ぶことで博物館という時間的にさかのぼってさまざまなストック
を持っているところがその事業のバックボーム役割を果たせると思ったからですそして
芸術祭という後を取り入れることで表現する人たちの酒店置かせていただく
音個の力で私たちは会津の魅力を漆を通して発見したり出会ったりできるのではないか
と考えました
100人ぐらいの作家さん職人さんたちが3年間毎年会津漆の芸術祭に参加して
くださいました
その皆さんの作品一つ一つがどれも強いメッセージを持っています
ここではその一つ一つをご紹介はできないのですがその一つを今回ご紹介いたします
まず2010年の一つです今ご覧いただいているのは宮原和仁さんという漆の作家さん
が作ら
れた作品です
この芸術祭の時は皆さんに博物館企画のツアーに参加していただいて作品を作って
いただきました
その土地の歴史それから漆の技を学んだ上で作品として伝えていただきたかったから
です
宮原さんは会津若松と喜多方の開場をツアーを巡った
結果としてきた形にある酒蔵の大和川し増産を展示会場に選びました
そして今皆さんがご覧くださっているように酒瓶が並んでいる場所でこの坂ブラで
かつてお酒造りの仕込みを家として使われてたを県の蓋を漆でかたどって作品にしたん
で
see
この土地のこの場所の歴史それはひいてはこのきた方の家がとても豊かでおいしい水に
恵まれて美味しい坂づくりを何百年にもわたってしてきたということの証でもあります
それを宮原さんは漆という永続性のとても高い素材を使ってこれから
将来にも残るメッセージとして残してくれたのです
こうしてこの土地と家にある歴史を
サッカーの視点で豊かに伝えていこうという私たちの試みは2011年以降も続いて
いくつもりで準備をしていたんですがここで大きく変化をせざるを得なくなります
2011年の3月11日に東
日本大震災が大きいその後に東京電力福島第1原子力発電所が爆発したからです
そこで私たちは2011年に行う漆の芸術祭のテーマを東北へのエールと変更しました
大今の表現者の人たちが皆さんそれぞれの表現手段で東北へのメッセージそして東北
から世界に発信すべきメッセージを作品を通して表現してくれました
現代美術の作家さんたちや他の漆や様々な表現し山の作家さんたちに肩を並べて頑張っ
てくださったのは
会津の漆の作り手たちです
今観ていただいているのは開いた圭介さんという漆の作り手の方がご自分が作られた
湿気を展示してくださったものです
開いたさんはご自身の器たちに再生の時代へというタイトルを付けました
ここには開いたさんのメッセージが込められています
2011年に起きたことから私たちは多くのことを学ぶことができました
消費し使ってエネルギーをたくさん作りそしてまた表皮するという酒井ではなくて何か
を繰り返し大切に守りつく使っていくようなそういう社会のあり方も必要なのではない
かと
開いたさんのこの器はメッセージとして伝えてくれています会津の多くの上
牛の作り手はそのようなことをメッセージとして伝えてくれたのですがそれは漆の
作り手たちが何十年もかけて育った木を分けてもらい数十年かけて作った漆の駅で塗り
ものを作るという自然から何かを分けてもらって長い時間のスパンの中でものづくりを
している人だ
あったからだと私は思っています
そして会津の職人さんたちがこうして2011年に私達のテーマを変更に応えて多くの
メッセージを発信してくださったことを今でもとても誇りに思っています
そして3年目となった2012年
私たちは漆の芸術祭のテーマ落ちの記憶未来へというものに変えました
ここではアートの力もまた確認することもできました
今皆さんがご覧になっている画像は9日以上のすぐお隣の場所です
末廣酒造さんが腰を創造している貯蔵庫にも作品を展示させていただきました
ここに展示されている白い小さな物体はある人とある人の握手の間で生まれた狭間の
作品です
2012年仮設住宅が福島県内でたくさん立つことができて非難していた方々がそちら
に映るようになっていった頃でした
会津にも旅館やホテルなどにたくさんの方が避難していました
避難していた皆さんが仮設住宅に移るにあたって何か
感謝の気持ちも大きく表したいそんな言葉も聞こえてきて
私たちは作家さんに相談をしましたそしてある作家さんが出してくれたアイディアが
その二人の間の握手の間を粘土を挟むことで記録してたらどうだろうということだった
んです
そして旅館やホテルのオーナーさんや従業員さん
そして避難してきた方達の間で生まれた握手の記憶が作家さんによって白い釉薬をかけ
られ
や蹴られやくやくことがされてこのように一つ一つの作品になっていきました
そしてこの白い一つ一つの小さな小さな
大切な作品たちは合図の漆の息人さんが作ってくれた大きな黒い漆塗りの円形の台の上
に展示されたのです
漆黒という言葉があります漆の黒ですよね
漆はとても深いそして輝くような苦労を出します
とても磨き上げられた黒い面というのは私たちの姿もほんのり映し出してくれるような
鏡面のような美しい姿も出すことがあります
ここで展示されたし
ロイ一人ひとりの手の間で生まれた
その記憶の形はこの星披露酒造さんの貯蔵庫の床に置かれて一人一人の記憶を映し出す
とともにこの土地の酒倉の記憶そして酒造りをしてきたこの土地の豊かな自然を
映し出していたようだな
と私は今でも思っています
こうしてアートは人と人をつないだりお互いのそういう思いやりの気持ちを私たちに
見せてくれたりということもありました
会津の家とはこうして避難してくれると竜星をたくさん受け入れて今も福島県の被害の
大きかった浜通りや中通りを支え続けています
私はこういうことは今後さらに必要になってくるのじゃないかなと思っています
なぜなら合図は今ご覧頂いている作品のように豊かな時間軸の上に成り立っている分野
文化や歴史が今も脈々と息づいていますそこに降り立って会津の地が福島をさせ
会えることということが今後とても必要になってくるんじゃないかと思っています
なぜなら浜通りと呼ばれている
原発が立地し大きな津波災害を受けた土地や中通りの地域の人たちは避難することで
その土地と切り離されてその土地の時間軸から離されて
しまうという危機にも枯れているからです
福島で避難しているいくつかの街村の中に飯舘村という場所があります
原発が立地しているところから離れているためにすぐにひなをするということではなく
て2011年の6月に前走比何が行われました
本当に青天の霹靂のようにまさかここでという思いの中で村民の人たちは避難していき
土地と話されたことで村の人たちの中には自分たちの文化が途切れてしまうんじゃない
かという危機感がとても大きいです
それは今も一緒です
私たち福島県立博物館は飯舘までの会という飯舘村を支援している団体の皆さんと一緒
に
そのミラーの姿をかつての文化を歴史を少しでも止めることができるようにということ
で飯舘ミュージアムという活動を2012年3年あたりから始めました
このプロジェクトは村の方たちにその人の歴史をお聞きしていきます大事にせることを
村での暮らしどんな生き方をしてきたのか
そんなお話の中からお話の中で象徴的なものを分けてもらってきています
例えば今ご覧いただいているのはなんとスズメバチの焼酎漬けです
こんなものがミュージアムの資料になるって思われますか
でもこれは立派ないいじゃてミュージアムの資料の一つです
これはある方のお話を聞いて頂いたものなんですがその方は定年後
炭が高じてそば打ちからさらに発展してソバづくりをしていました
ご存知の方もいらっしゃいますがおそばというのは稲でよりももうちょっと寒い寒冷な
土地を好んで実る作物です
飯舘村はお米に育てるにはちょっと適していなくて
昔は例外の時にはなくなる方もいたぐらいの寒冷な土地なのですがそばづくりには
とても適していました
そこで定年後に楽しく仲間たちとソバづくりをしていた方は自分のためにミツバチを
買います
そうするとミツバチを狙ってスズメバチがやってきましたそれをその男性はヒュッと網
で取っては焼酎にすっとつけていたんだそうです
どうして生まれたこのスズメバチ
の焼酎漬けはその方のこの数年間の仲間たちとのある意味での食文化のような暮らしを
伝えてくれるものでもあります
飯舘村の自然を伝えてくれるものでもあります
こういう何気ないもの一つ一つから私たちは今
途切れてしまうかもしれない飯舘村の時間値
空を少しでもつなげることができればと思っています
そして今ご紹介しているのはある方のお宅の茶の間に貼られていた神です
ここに書かれている数値は事故から6カ月後つまり
2011年の3月の6カ月後から
避難した飯舘村の方が自宅に戻るたびにそのお家の中そして周囲で測った放射線量を
メモしたものです
カレンダーの裏に目上書をして茶の葉に貼り付ける誰でもする行為ですよね
その何気ない暮らしの中に放射線量という何気なくないものが東京してしまっているの
が飯舘村の今の状況ですそれは福島県のほかの地域でもあることでしょうそれが
暮らし
の一部でありある意味ではその地区土地の時間軸の一つのところに刻まれてしまったと
いう現実も私たちは受け止めねばなりません
皆様はこの時間軸にキズマれたひとつの事象どんな風に受け止められますか
私たちはこうして博物館だからできることを行うと一緒に会津漆の芸術祭の時に行った
ようにアーティストの力を借りそしてアートの力を借りて福島のことを記録することも
行なっています
浜中 is 文化連携プロジェクトという福島県の段
各団体 npo さんや大学さんや文化施設と一緒に行っている事業ではいくつかの
プロジェクトを行っているんですが
岡部昌生さんというフロッタージュをする作家参入が2012年から参加をして
いただいています
これは岡部さんの飯舘村でへ
石碑のフロット味をとっているところです
人が住むことができなくなりもしかしたらもうしばらくはその時間軸を誰か月な寝て
ますなネイルは鳴かなくなったような土地でそので土地の歴史を少しでも残すことが
できればという思いもあって
石碑のフロッタージュを行っていきました
そして津波被災地の歴史も刻んでいます
この画像は南相馬市で行なっていたフロッタージュの制作の様子です
津波によって大きなものがたくさん流されていきました
もちろん建物もたくさん流されていきました
今ご覧いただいているのは南相馬市の沿岸部の住宅が流され残された基礎です
この基礎の上に大きなものがたくさん流された後に付いた傷跡が残っていました
フィロっタージという技法はその数かな気配を
方のように紙に刻みつかむことができます
視力媚薬負荷ビアなっているところは凹んでいるところ
黒く残って描かれているところは上に
コンクリートが残っているところですつまり白くなっているところは傷が付けられた後
なんですね
コンクリートに傷がつくほど重たいあるいは硬いものがすごい勢いで流されてこなくて
はこんな傷跡はつきません
岡部さんはこの土地の時間軸の一つとなってしまったこの津波の記録をもこうして
私たちと一緒に記録してくれています
そしてここ数年間の活動として行われているのが女性によって行われたの新たに生まれ
てしまった福島の状況の記録です
これは飯舘村のある神社なんですが除染のため大きなご神木を切らねばならなくなり
ました
長い年月氏子の皆さんや神社を見守ってきた
大事な際時な御神木です氏子の皆さん宮司さんたちは悩んで悩んで悩んだ結果仕方が
ないということできることに決めたそうです
今観ていただいてもとても大きな木だということがわかると思います
岡部さんはこのきりかぶお風呂ッターズの技法でこすり取ることでこの木の年輪から
その木の大きさ
そしてここで飯舘の人たちを見守ってきた年月の長さを伝えてくれましたそして同時に
とても
を無残に残っている低層の傷跡は私たちがそれを切り倒すという選択をこの土地の人
たちに敷いてしまったという事実をも伝えています
このこともまたこの飯舘の時間軸の中に刻まれたひとつです
こうして生まれた作品たちは展示という手法で伝えることができています
伝えるという博物館の役割はこうして展示することの中で果たせているのかなぁとも
思っています
私たちはこうして博物館だからできることをそして伝えることに試みてきました
そして今私たちがこうして行なってきた活動のほんのわずかのことですが皆さんにお
伝えしてそして考えて欲しいなぁと思っているのはみなさんお一人お一人にも時間地区
があるということです
今ここにいらっしゃる皆さんが性を受けた瞬間のその先祖に連なる時間軸はもちろん
ですけれども
ここの末廣酒造さんでコースてばをご一緒させていただいている時間を共有できている
のも
成広さんのここにへ酒造りを始められて繋いできたこの数百年
の歴史の積み重ねがあって私たちはここに今立てています
そのように皆さんのそれぞれがを持ちの時間軸は多くのいろんな時間軸の組み合わせで
織物織りなすようにして成り立っています
ぜひ皆さんの時間軸一つ一つを振り返ってみてください
私たち博物館はきっと皆さんがその時間軸を振り返る時にお役に立つのではないかなと
思っています
そして
時間軸を振り返るということはみなさんが携わっているいろんな物事やそれからその
土地
訪れた土地働く土地いろんな土地への思いをまた変えてくれる力があるのではないかな
とも思っています
更にもう一つ言わせていただくといろんな時間軸の先端の集合体が今になっています
この同じ現代を生きる私たちのもう一つ一つの時間軸はこうやって時間を共有すること
で交わることもありますがオープ知らないままそれぞれが時間軸を積み重ねること
もあります
しかし違う離れたところにある岩となりの声をかけない大彼の持っている時間軸を知る
ことあるいは
見つけることで何か別の発見があることもあると思います
それが別の社会あるいは別の考え方駅方を知ることにつながるのではないでしょうか
そんなとききっとアーティストやアートの目線は皆さんの心の中にある何かのスイッチ
を探し当ててスイッチが入れる入る時のお手伝いをしてくれると思っています是非
博物館とそしてアートを信じて皆さんの時間軸と心の中のスイッチを探し
てみてくださいそうすることで私は社会がちょっとずつ変わっていくのではないかなと
思っています以上です
[拍手]